I've got the very first Apple TV set-top
box i still use it all the time but
haven't felt the need for an upgrade how
much better does this new set-top box
how much better could it be and will it
be the update that encourages people to
upgrade hey and Emily I think it can get
a lot better I think that there are
definitely apps they could develop to be
more engaging if you look at what
comcast is done with Xfinity for example
they've added a voice enabled controller
of a voice enabled remote control
they've added apps that allow you to get
scores from one show or from a game
while you're watching another show
there's a lot of stuff that Apple could
add to make it a more engaging
experience and I absolutely think voices
top on the list Hunter you worked at
YouTube for many many years you are also
a writer on late night television you
wrote for Conan but how optimistic are
you about the potential for Apple to be
a big player in the streaming might be a
business I think ultimately they have a
shot to be quite a significant player
but it's not just because of an apple TV
device because of the iOS ecosystem and
the fact that we already have a remote
control in our pocket or on our desk in
the iphone and the ipad if you look at
amazon's bestseller list though the fire
stick in google chromecast have been
number one and number two for months
over months of our months so apples
coming late to this party of making more
and more dumb TVs into smart devices you
know they've called it a hobby but I
think they need to turn it into
something serious pretty quick Bob what
do you think this signifies about a
potential streaming service which as far
as we've heard has been push back push
back push back push back and a TV set
has been shelved yeah I think it it's
actually an independent thing it's easy
to throw the two together but my guess
is any TV service they offer is going to
work on existing Apple TV boxes too
they're not going to want to make it
just work with the newest devices I
think but what this does is Crawford
pointed out is it allows them to have
more horsepower so that they can run
applications and do things like overlay
content from one program on to another
program and do the kinds of things that
frankly I saw in smart TV demos 10 years
ago that we still haven't really seen in
the marketplace now I want to make a
quick turn to Samsung because Samsung
as I mentioned earlier 10 billion
dollars wiped off Samsung's market cap
they really misjudged how many s6 galaxy
s6 phones and s6 edge phones were going
to sell Crawford to you you know Samsung
it has now lost its dominant position in
China apple and xiaomi are jockeying for
the top spot there is Samsung in
jeopardy of losing its dominance in the
global smartphone market yeah they are I
mean they absolutely are in jeopardy of
losing it but I will tell you that the
progress out of that company is
significant I think when you look at the
two most recent products that they
brought out they've frankly never been
better and yeah they blew it on demand
but and it's in terms of forecasting
demand but I would actually put i would
say that six months ago what you're
seeing in the in the results today
represent the bad decisions that were
made six months in a year ago and I
actually think that they're now on an
upswing and we may be seeing kind of a
bottom here for samsung Bob yeah I mean
I think there are challenges for the
smartphone market period and that's
gonna impact Samsung its eventually I
think even gonna impact Apple but what
about the upgrade cycle that's feeding
up and I don't think it is I think it's
lengthening and I think that's one of
the challenges that they're facing we're
also seeing that on the high end where
Samsung has focused a lot of their
efforts you know it's going to be very
very difficult the other thing is I
think we're seeing the transformation of
Samsung as a company it's gonna be
harder and harder to make money on
devices they're looking at more and more
on the semiconductor and components side
and there's better margins there it's a
much different company just like sony
has evolved i think samsung may follow a
similar type of pet what about the brand
i mean even tom brady as you as you say
that the the earnings announcement
wasn't great but tom brady saying he
threw out his s6 to switch to an iphone
and that's why he couldn't turn data
over to the NFL investigators that might
have been the biggest loss of the week